why did you make that decision to try
not being the CEO of the company you
co-founded I want the best for Flex
board I had a banker told him hey here's
what I'm looking for he's like oh you
should hire Dave Clark I was like come
on man he's the CEO of Amazon he's like
he he might be open to it let's talk to
him and turned out he was it quickly
went sideways you just realized I need
to come back and I made a mistake joural
has kind of dug up a bunch of drama that
didn't exist they interviewed somebody
who told him all this stuff about Dave
that wasn't true then told Dave it was
someone close to the company Dave then
thought I was the one saying bad things
about him and he's like oh if they're
going to make these allegations against
me we're at War and started attacking
the company there was a decision made by
our board Dave was going big and the
board made this decision that like hey
this isn't the right path we have to cut
costs we also need to maintain intimacy
like how we meet with customers and grow
with the customer and how we build the
culture of our team and that's a very
hard job for a hired CEO to do to both
be like I'm cutting cost and I care
about the culture a lot this would be a
better role for the founder